كنا نتحدث اذا عن اجتماع مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي للبت في ما اذا كانت هناك
مقاربه جديده فيما يخص تبادل الاسرى رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو طالب
اعضاء حكومته بالاصغاء الى اصوات عائلات
الجنود الذين قتلوا في المعارك الدائره في
غزه وتلى في كلمته امام حكومته اليوم ما
قال انها وصيه اهالي هؤلاء
الجنود اريد ان اقرا على مسامعكم رساله
وصلتني هذا الصباح من عائلات جنودنا
الابطال الذين سقطوا في المعارك لقد كتبوا
لي يقولون ان الشعب قوي وصامد وان الجنود
والمواطنين ابطال ومصممون على تحقيق النصر
المطلق ونفوض بالقتال وليس بوقفه في منتصف
الطريق هذه وصيه الذين سقطوا وهذا وجبنا
تجاه
الاحياء ومعنا من ميدان المحتجزين في
تلبيب مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان
اذا
مجلس الحربي يجتمع على البث في هذا الامر
وحسب هيئه البث الاسرائيليه في خبر عاجل
يبث الان اسرائيل تدرس اطلاق اسرى نوعيين
من اصحاب
المحكومية منحى جديد لصفقه تبادل في اثر
الضغوطات الكثيره التي حصلت في الايام
الاخيره الماضيه بعد الاعلان عن مقتل او
قتل الجيش الاسرائيلي لثلاثه من المحتجزين
في داخل غزه العائلات بدات ربما او صعدت
من حراكها ل الضغط اكثر على الحكومه لكن
بالرغم من حديث نتنياهو هذا اليوم في جلسه
الحكومه الاسبوع ووعيه عن ان احد اهداف
هذه الحرب او كرر عمليا ما يتحدث به دائما
بان احد اهداف هذه الحرب
هو استعاده المحتجزين من غزه الا انه
استهل الجلسه تحديدا بما هو عكس ذلك وفقا
لاقوال ه تحدث عما وصفها رساله وصلته صباح
هذا اليوم من عشرات عائلات الجنود القتلى
خلال الحرب مما ممن طالبوه بعدم
التوقف وعدم وقف الحرب او وقف اطلاق النار
والتوقف في منتصف الطريق وفقا لما قراه
على وزراء الحكومه هذا اليوم و وقال بان
هذه هي وصيه القتلى من الجنود وان الحكومه
ملتزمه بتنفيذ هذه الوصيه بمعنى انه من
جهه يتحدث عن ان اسرائيل تحاول وتبذل كل
الجهود من اجل استعاده المحتجزين لكنه
استهل جلسه الحكومه بهذه الاقوال هذا
اليوم وهو ما يعتبر عمليا عكس العكس تماما
من العمل على اعاده المحتجزين كانت هناك
صحيفه هارتس هذا اليوم قد اشارت في مقال
تحدثت فيه عن لقاء جمع بين اهالي
المحتجزين يوم امس وبين وزير الوزير بيني
جانس والوزير جالنت وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي وقالت فيه بان جانس تحديدا
ربما عبر عن انه بالفعل لن يفوت اي
امكانيه للقيام بذلك من اجل الافراج عن ال
المحتجزين لكن هناك طلب كان واضحا من هذه
العائلات ان تتوق ان يتوقف الجيس الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن اي محاولات للافراج عن ال
المحتجزين في غزه عبر عمليات عسكريه بسبب
خشيتهم من ان يكون مصيرهم كمصير اخرين
قتلوا خلال هذه العمليات عمليات محاوله
الاستعاده والتخليص او ان يقتلوا كما حدث
في الحادث يوم الجمعه في حي الشجاعيه
ثلاثه من المحتجزين قتلهم الجيش شكرا
جزيلا لك من ميدان المحتجزين في تل ابيب
مراسله الجزيره نجوان زبري